let's get an update now on the situation
in Gaza this Tuesday morning yumna alad
is our correspondent on the ground yumna
Gaza was in complete darkness overnight
just bring us up to speed with the
situation this morning what's been
happening are the air strikes are as
intense as they were a few hours
ago well Folly it was a very very tough
night for the Gaza Strip over 200 air
strikes took place in different areas of
the Gaza trip um I can't I can't
remember one uh uh piece of land in Gaza
or one territory that has not been
targeted yesterday uh whether it's
residential buildings neighborhoods uh
residential neighborhoods uh uh
commercial neighborhoods you can you can
just uh imagine how the bombardments
went on now with Gaza not having
electricity uh more than four hours of
electricity that was in the past two
days now we are even witnessing a a more
deficit in in in in the in the 80%
deficit that we have witnessed in the
past two days where we only had 4 hours
of electricity in 24 hours now the so
power plant is saying that it can
operate for maximum two more days and
that's when the entire Gaza Strip won't
have one hour of electricity unless fuel
enters Gaza now this is how big the
crisis is in the Gaza Strip when it
comes to electricity not just civilians
are are suffering the the loss of
electricity we're talking about
hospitals we're talking about uh uh
water we're talking about h a complete
darkness overshadowing the Gaza Strip it
it is truly um incredible to to try to
understand how people can cope under
these conditions extremely difficult
conditions with no power no water and no
food and Relentless Israeli bombardments
yumna we are looking on the left side of
our screen right now at the Skies over
Gaza with plumes of smoke still
billowing high up in the skies there can
you tell us about the situation this
morning as you said it's been a very
difficult night for you all there what
is it like this morning and how are
people coping under these difficult
circumstances well after all uh the
violent bombardments overnight we had
about an hour of relative calm in the
Gaza City and uh around Gaza City but in
the South there were a couple of
bombardments now bombardments are
returning again they're uh reoccurring
again in different areas um uh people
just wanted to get an hour or two of
sleep to rest after the violent raids
they're they're going on now uh if
you've heard the sound uh we have over
uh 3,000 uh people that are that were in
the streets yesterday they were
literally in the streets of hospitals uh
T haa neighborhood AAL neighborhood uh
these two uh uh these two and the and
the surrounding of the universities the
campus of the universities these three
areas were violently bombarded yesterday
families from those areas that managed
or had to evacuate their homes and there
was no enough space in un schools to go
to they went to alz University in telwa
neighborhood they stayed right there in
uh the yards of Al uh and in the
reception of Al put's Hospital uh we
were we were told by the Ministry of
Health that about 3,000 people were in
the hospitals yesterday just out there
in the street with their kids with their
with their families uh trying to find
shelter in the midst of all this
bombardment going on other people who
were not able to come out of their
buildings that their surroundings were
bombard bombarded uh stayed in their
buildings they stayed in the basements
of their buildings and they just uh they
just stayed there uh like they're
imprisoned in these basements they're
like they're imprisoned in their homes
many of these buildings in Gaza have
been leveled to the ground as we can see
on the latest pictures we've been
receiving it looks like a war zone
really and people forced from their
homes as yumna was saying there with
nowhere to go thank you yumna for the
update for the moment yal s live Forest
there in Gaza City well let's now speak
to a Gaza resident Maha husseini who's
the strategy director at euromed Human
Rights monitor she's joining us from uh
Gaza Maha thank you so much for taking
the time to to be with us today on aler
can I ask you first how the night was
for you and your loved
ones thank you very much and good
morning um actually uh tonight was also
one of the harshest nights since the
beginning of the uh attack on Gaza uh
many residential reor hoods have been
targeted until now the uh artillery
Israeli artillery have join has joined
also the naval and iral forces um uh in
bombing different districts of the Gaza
Strip uh maybe tonight um uh the south
of the Gaza Strip has uh or was bearing
the brunt of these attacks um in the uh
early hours of the night also uh the
south of the Gaza City in particular has
been also uh bombed in a large scale
bombardment um whole neighborhoods and
whole squares of residential
neighborhoods have been evacuated of
residents um these numbers of people can
can be estimated at around 50,000 people
who have been uh evacuated from their
homes in order for the Israeli uh forces
to bombard whole squares and to wipe out
entire neighborhoods in Gaza uh but what
we are talking about here is the
harshest of the situation is
people have nowhere to go there have no
shelters uh currently we're talking
about 180,000 people who are displaced
or even more this this number I'm
talking about was uh in the last night
but we are now after a whole night of
Relentless bumping we are talking about
uh thousands others who have been
displaced now a large portion of these
people displaced at are at unoa schools
others are staying at relatives homes in
relatively safer areas although there
are no safe areas here in Gaza but the
the evacuation from one area to another
depends on the place of bombing so
people leave from a targeted bombing in
order to go to an area that will be
targeted in the future or the upcoming
hours I was going yeah I was going to
ask you Maha where are the safe areas
yourself for example you know where
where are you able to feel safe and how
do you cope throughout the night with
this Relentless
bombing uh I don't feel safe no one's
feel safe here in Gaza even us as human
rights workers working at International
organizations journalists Etc we do not
feel safe there is no place that is that
can be deemed safe here in Gaza I live
in a residential building in a totally
civilian area uh particularly in t Hawa
Street and you can know that T Street
was largely uh bonded last night and the
night before uh I can see buildings from
my window being targeted at being bonded
um um we have uh throughout the past
three days um we have been breathing
actually uh smoke coming out of
buildings targeted in front of us so um
I I cannot say that this this is a safe
place and I am expecting at any moment
that we would be evacuating or a place
in our uh residential neighborhood might
be targeted for example we have already
prepared our evacuation bags so that we
can leave at any moment but honestly I
do not have a plan B my family does not
have a plan B no one has a plan B to go
where to go we have no idea where we
will go be going but this as I said
depends on the place of bumping we might
be leaving to relatives homes that are
in other areas that are not targeted Etc
but we know that even when we go to
these areas we might be targeted for
example yesterday Israel um or the two
days ago Israel sent text messages the
the IDF to thousands of civilians and uh
residents of the north of Gaza
particularly Bon area they asked them to
leave and evacuate to the center of the
uh City and after they have left to the
center of the city a few hours later
they were bumped in the center of the in
the local market of jabalia refugee camp
so even the evacuation yeah yeah Maha as
as you're talking now we're hearing
fresh strikes again on the Gaza Strip
fresh Israeli strikes this Tuesday
Morning um not clear yet where those
strikes are happening on on what in what
part of the territory that's happening
but they are again after the relative
calm that our correspondent was
describing uh this morning it seems that
it started again uh what is also
concerning Maha in all this is in
addition to the bombing to the
Relentless aerial bombing by Israel Gaza
is also now under total Siege with no
food no water no electricity coming in
how long can gaza's residents hold out
for exactly this is adding this is like
adding insult to the injury uh since day
one of the attack actually uh Israel
declared that it would cut and it
already cut electricity supplies to the
Gaza trip so since day one we have been
um uh without electricity we have been
relying mainly on power generators but
yesterday they have uh announced that uh
Gaza is under total Siege with no food
no electricity no medications and no
water supply and Etc um this is like a
total blackout they are leaving the two
million residents the over two million
residents in Gaza in Total Blackout and
what is also exacerbating the the
situation the and the crisis is that
Israel is actually targeting um
telecommunication companies here in Gaza
the main the two main telecommunication
companies which are palel and jaal which
are totally independent uh uh
Palestinian businesses have been
targeted the headquarters of these
buildings which are located in one of
the in two of the densely populated and
most more uh most vital populated areas
in Gaza have been targeted the whole
buildings of these companies were
targeted and uh as as a result we have
been facing even difficulties in making
calls being connected to the internet
and also uh staying connected to the
entire the outside world uh after the
attack uh that took place yesterday we
haven't been able actually to call our
relatives to make sure they are okay in
these areas Etc because there were no
connection and in large areas of the
Gaza Strip uh my colleagues have been
reporting that they are out of internet
for the past two days the the internet
connection is also very poor uh it's
very um uh weak here and um actually our
worst concern and our worst fear here in
Gaza is not just being bumped not just
being wiped out but also being wiped out
out while being in a total blackout
while being silenced and being cut off
of of the world Maha thank you so very
much for taking the time to speak to us
about your experience what you're going
through right now Maha husseini is
strategy strategy director at euromed
Human Rights monitor uh in Gaza thank
you for your time